let's deal with some audience questions
right now we have three good ones first
one is from Karen Karen says David can
you give us an update on the fainting
situation yes five years ago I fainted
on a flight to Portugal I thought that
that was over and done with but a few I
guess at this point it's been like six
weeks ago I fainted on the way back from
Italy and more than likely it's been
diagnosed as a vasovagal syncope
although I did undergo some tests of my
heart previously I underwent some tests
some brain to see if it's a neurological
issue that was clear I am still
finalizing waiting on the final results
about the heart issue and the question
is did I just faint because I have a
tendency towards low blood pressure and
I was dehydrated and I had a glass of
wine on the flight and I was sort of on
an empty stomach and then had a big meal
on the plane and all of this generated a
situation that lowered my blood pressure
or did I have like some kind of acute
heart arrhythmia or very very like
dangerously low heart rate at the time
etc that has not yet been ruled out my
cardiologist said this is sort of like
an abundance of caution we want to make
sure this isn't the case has not yet
finalized I should know more around
close to Thanksgiving so that's that's
where that is right now and of course
I'll let everybody know what goes on at
the end I'm somewhat nervous about what
this might turn up although I've
basically been told that it's pretty
unlikely that that's the issue I have a
history of fainting once every few years
since I was a little kid it used to be
just when I would get up in the middle
of the night to go to the bathroom and
stand up right away and all the blood
would leave my brain my head and it was
lower my blood pressure and I would
faint and the the sort of idea of my
doctor is that this is something similar
going on whatever the answer is I want
to be able to get some specific guidance
as to what to do to prevent this from
happening and when I flew to Vegas a
couple weeks ago I was super careful to
you know stay hydrated and do all of
these things that you're supposed to do
when I was fine but it feels still like
it's very much by chance you know well
the good thing is that this happens once
every few years you've kind of kicked
the can down the road for a while you
don't have to
really concerned yourself too much for a
while I guess but the the the idea of
not knowing exactly what does cause it
that's really the scary part so
hopefully we can get some answers
ideally we'll rule out the heart thing
and then get some answers about what's
going on but that is the latest as far
as the fainting goes